Donald Trump has suffered a major loss and
we've taken one giant step towards seeing
Donald Trump's tax return
returns. And Donald Trump is furious and he
has ordered, uh, he has been ordered to turn
over eight years of his and his company's
tax returns. And I'll explain the entire trajectory
to you. I've told you before, the Manhattan
district attorney is investigating Donald
Trump's company for criminality and requested
a bunch of personal and corporate tax returns.
Trump immediately sued to stop the release
of those taxes. A federal judge has now dismissed
the lawsuit, meaning that unless Donald Trump
can come up with some new reason, uh, to block
the release of those returns to the Manhattan
da, he is going to have to provide them or
will he? Right? Because what I mean is the
consequences for Trump so far for just not
doing what he's told when it comes to providing
documents have been zero. But it is a step,
a step in the right direction. The argument
that Donald Trump made to prevent the release
of these tax returns was that as president,
he is immune, not just from criminal prosecution,
which of course he believes, but that's a
broader question, but that he is immune also
from even being criminally investigated, period.
Now judge Victor Marrero, [inaudible] Hispanic
guy, Trump might lose it anyway, judge Victor
Marrero says that that's not gonna fly, rejected
the argument altogether and says, Trump's
gotta provide the tax returns. And in the
immediate hours that followed, Donald Trump's
lawyers appealed it and the U S circuit court
has granted Donald Trump a stay saying, okay,
if you're appealing it, we will delay forcing
Trump to provide those tax returns. But this
is now one bullet that's been fired by Trump
and the bullet has missed Trump, of course,
furious blaming, radical left Democrats on
Twitter saying quote, the radical left Democrats,
capital R capital L naturally have failed
on all fronts. So now they are pushing local
New York city and state Democrat prosecutors
to go get president Trump. A thing like this
has never happened to any president before,
not even close. So what's going to happen
here? I'm going to give you like the Mo, the
realist assessment of what I think is going
to go down.
I believe that Donald Trump will use every
single option that he can. He will exhaust
every crazy notion to avoid having to provide
these tax returns. And meanwhile he will further
the witch hunt narrative like he did on Russia
like he's doing on Ukraine. There's a good
chance it's not 100% but there's a good chance
that at some point a judge will say, listen,
legally, you've got to provide your tax returns
to investigators. They will then put out,
just like the bar letter, just like the truncated
memo about the Ukraine phone call. They will
put out some completely edited tax returns
that he will claim our complete records and
then investigators and Democrats will correctly
say no, but this is BS. These are completely
incomplete. And then Trump will say, look,
I finally give them to you and you still don't
like them. And before you know it, it'll be
the 2020 election and Donald Trump will win
reelection.
That that's a, a combination of realistic
and sort of cynical assessment, which I do
happen to think is actually the most likely
assessment of what's going to go on here.
And in the end we will go get back to what
is in Trump's taxes that he is so desperately
and for so many years fought tooth and nail
to prevent their reliefs. And the answer is
several things, speculation. But if we wonder,
given what we know about Trump, given what
we know about Trump's ego, given what we know
about Trump's shady business connections to
use a very light term that is probably too
understated, we could learn from Trump's taxes
that he is not nearly as wealthy as he claims
we could learn from Trump's taxes. I mean,
it's almost guaranteed that he inflates the
values of assets to get loans and that those
assets actually aren't worth that much.
And on the taxes, he may even understate the
values of those assets. We may learn the names
of the shell companies and all sorts of forensic
accounting leads for more things to look into.
We could learn about various types of fraud
because what is on Trump's taxes may not be
in line with other financial disclosures and
loan applications and things that Donald Trump
has previously disclosed. There are many possibilities
here, but let me say this because apparently
this is totally legal and totally cool to
say. Now, Kurdish hackers, if you're listening,
Icelandic hackers, whoever, if you're listening,
if you were to find Donald Trump's taxes,
I believe the media would greatly reward you.
Trump said it about Hillary's emails to Russia
can't be anything wrong with me saying it
to Kurdish hackers and Icelandic hackers about
Donald Trump's taxes. Just saying, I'm guessing
the media would greatly reward you.